I had a bit of a dilemma with this talk
just too many slides and so it's always
hard to cut stuff away and what I
decided to do instead was use the drink
from a fire hose approach which is to
just leave them in and there are a whole
bunch of slides which only need 10
seconds and that's all I'm going to give
them and so the burden is on you that if
you see something go by that you want me
to stop and dwell on just yell make some
audible noise like pause stop whoa
something like that so that I'll know
that you'd like me to dwell there I
you'll see a few of these adjust I
didn't want to delete them but they only
they really only take a few seconds okay
so what motivated this talk is I live in
a C++ world but I do have clients who
are still using just C and what I found
is a lot of them are still using C 90
with just a little bit of c 99 thrown in
and so the every so often i get somebody
who's interested in knowing well what am
i missing out on and so this is gonna
cover things that i think it's not a
completely exhaustive set but these are
things which i think you're interesting
also if you live in the c++ world it is
interesting just as a student of
languages to see the different
sensibilities of the c standardization
effort and c++ and so that i think even
if you live in a c++ world mostly it's
still kind of interesting to see because
there's a fair amount of
cross-pollination that occurs where
something originates in C and then winds
up in C++ and vice-versa
okay very briefly here's the timeline
it's that there really have been four
standards for the C language C 89 and 90
are essentially the same thing
89 was the US standard and 90 was the
international version of that same
standard so most of us just refer to it
as c90 c90 9 then 2011 they
were substantive additions probably the
biggest incremental change was between
90 and 99 11 then added a bunch of other
things and then 18 is essentially just
11 with wording changes refinements
there's and it's supposed to be no
feature changes it's similar to the
situation in C++ but with having to do
with C++ O 3 and 98 which are
essentially the same language one thing
that I think is very interesting is a
philosophical attitude that is much more
prominent in the C standardization
effort than in C++ which is that they
have a I think a greater concern for not
breaking existing code in other words if
something is compiling with the current
generation of compilers the sikh
community tries harder to make it that
when the new standard comes out the old
code still works and that manifests
itself particularly in the treatment of
keywords and and and new identifiers so
what I'm talking about is this is
there's a set of headers it's about 40
standard headers and they all have
well-documented identifiers that are
published there so if you include for
example standard IO dot H everybody
knows you get EOF and file and printf
and things like that
but you also get the possibility of a
handful of names that you don't know
about it one of the common examples is
that the data type file is often
implemented as a type def which is an
alias for some structure type whose name
you're not supposed to know but the
problem is how do you avoid
inadvertently creating a name that's
spelled the same that could cause a
compilation problem another example
where this crops up is that there is a
rule with it with the exception of the
header assert dot H the idea is that any
header should be allowed standard header
should be
allowed to be included more than once
and in any order with respect to the
other standard headers and there's a
common idiom for implementing this which
you all know which is to use include
guards and the problem is that the
include guards require identifiers for
the names of the macros which are used
in the include guards so and the problem
is if you inadvertently use one of those
names you're going to have compilation
problems and there is a standard way of
staying away from those names and that
is that the standard has this notion of
reserved identifiers and and the idea is
that there are rules for forming
identifiers that the standard says just
don't use these and it's your obligation
as a programmer to know what those rules
are and fortunately the rules are pretty
simple the rule one rule is that any
name that begins with an underscore and
a lowercase lever letter is reserved for
use at global scope turns out you're
allowed to use these names as structure
members and local variables you're just
not allowed to use them as global names
the other category of reserved
identifiers they're things that begin
with two underscores or an underscore in
a capital letter and those are reserved
absolutely for all uses you just never
invent your own names with that spelling
convention now here's how this impacts
you this is observable behavior that you
can see in the standardization effort
and one good example is the way that C
treats the boolean type originally C
didn't have a boolean type so it was
common practice among C programmers who
had experience in any other language to
fashion their own boolean Titan C
programmers who had only known C thought
that boolean z' were integers with the
values 0 and nonzero but those of us who
have multilingual explicit oh how can
you get by without a boolean type the
problem was people would conjure up the
boolean type differently some people
made it a type def in which true and
Falls were macro definitions others made
it an enumeration type so that when c99
added the boolean type they had to make
sure that it didn't break code and so
they used a reserved identifier for the
keyword in particular the the name of
the standard boolean type in C that was
added in c99 was underscore capital B
bool and the reason for that was that
this was a name that was in the pool of
reserved identifiers which means that if
you had been using this you were already
writing a program with undefined
behavior and the standards attitude was
now you get what you deserve and so they
could safely use that as the new type
and so it was a reserved identifier now
its keyword and and you'll see this
pattern in a number of the other
features that we're going to discuss so
if you want to use the more aesthetic
spelling which is bool all in lowercase
you have to include a header standard
bullet and when you do not only do you
get bool but you get false and true and
this C standard took this approach
because they say if you know that you
can get these names now added to your
program without any conflict go ahead
and include standard voltage now
interestingly C++ couldn't take this
approach C++ had to make bool a keyword
and the reason is that the overloading
rules in C++ say that if we had just use
a type def then that's not a unique type
for the purposes of overloading if we
want to be able to overload on bull it
has to be a clearly distinct type and so
they say okay I can't figure out how to
do this other than make it a keyword and
so you see that the C++ language for
legitimate reasons couldn't be quite as
deferential
to existing code as the C language has
been now one of the other concerns that
the Sikh community C++ community had was
we'd like to know whether or not you're
compiling with a standard C compiler C
would when seen 90 came out that was the
first standard and so one of the
questions that people would want to know
is well am i compiling now with a
standard compiler or do I have to do
some things to dance around the fact
that I'm compiling with a pre standard
compiler so the way this was handled in
C 90 was to introduce this macro called
underscore underscore standard stood C
underscore underscore whose value was
either 0 or 1 and you could use these in
conditionals in order to be able to say
nothing can I rely on all the features
of standard C now this is a classic
example though of not planning ahead
because the next standard came out with
new features and immediately the
question wasn't is it standard or not
but which standard is it and so they
solved that by introducing another they
didn't get rid of stood C they added
another one which is stood C version and
this is what you use to disturb oast
parts stood C is now not particularly
interesting this is the one that is
interesting and this is also there's
something like this in C++ as well
because C++ has to deal with the same
issue and the choice of the values for
stood see the macro is a sequence of
digits a long integer essentially whose
numeric value is the month and year in
which the standard came out so that 2017
10 is the date that it is considered
that the 20 that's actually the C 18
standard came out some some of the
insiders actually refer to it as C 17
but those of us involved in
standardisation process know that
there's a lag but
between the time the committee says
we're done and the the time the the ISO
hierarchy finally puts the stamp of
approval on it so you can test am i
compiling with c18 by comparing the
macro stood C version to that value you
say well if it's not C 18 is it C 11 and
if it's not c11 is it C 99 and if it's
not is it at least standard C and if
it's not that then you say well I I I'm
dealing with something really ancient
here and so you can ask that question
through in the form of a and if def like
this now C 99 has a fair number of
features which are in common with C++ in
some cases they're identical in others
there are minor variations and I'll try
to point out those variations as we go
the first one is the slash last comment
that's an example of a slide which
merits three seconds or less the long
long integer types the extended integer
types relax declaration ordering and
declarations and for statements let's
just he hit each of them these really
quickly and you'll stop me if you see
anything that you'd like a question now
by the way in lining and complex
arithmetic or also things that C shares
in common with C++ but there are clear
differences which we'll take a moment to
point out there we go slash slash
comments the thing I want to say about
this is my understanding I was not on
this I was on the C committee way back
in the 80s but when they got around to
after they finished the c90 standard and
we're looking at what do we do for the
next standard by the way the common
practice is that many of these standards
committees release a standard and then
they sort of go dormant for a while
I think the obligation is that
have to meet again within something like
five years to decide the question is do
we keep the standard as is is it now
obsolete and nobody cares about it or
are there certain things we'd like to
add or tweak but as we've seen with the
C++ committee then it's just a
never-ending churn of activity they
don't you know who wants to go to sleep
for a little while like we got so much
to do it hasn't been and so the first
thing that the C committee did was they
started to look at the list of things
that C++ had added and said are there
any of these that we would like to
borrow and incorporate into C 19 C
whatever it is after C 90 and it turned
out that every single feature was
controversial except one and that was
this this one that was it was you I
think unanimous let's just do it other
than that this requires no additional
elaboration the long long integer type
believe that originated in C and was
borrowed over into C++ it's not just the
addition of you know that you can now
say long long instead of just long and
it wasn't enough to just add the type
the type required some additional
support from the library in particular
functions like ADA L or the lab's
function for computing absolute value
had to be augmented to include ll
versions of those functions also things
like printf and scanf had to be
augmented with format specifiers and
that was the extent of the support for
that exact with integer types most
people know about these but there is an
aspect of it which is worth pointing out
and this trade is also common with C++
which is that as you all know there's a
certain amount of implementation to find
slack in the sizes of all of the
arithmetic types and it's an aid to
portability in a lot of respects but
it's also a real nuisance for people who
have specific range requirements they
need to know how many what's the range
of values of an
and so it became common practice early
on for people to invent their own
fixed-width types and it was such a
common thing that finally the Standards
Committee let's just standardize a set
and this set they standardized was
placed in a header file called stood in
th and c plus plus provides essentially
the same header and as common in this
case the names that are in the c 99
version are all global names in the C++
version which is C stood int the names
are all members of namespace STD that's
the essential difference and most of you
are familiar with the the int and you
int underscore T names and there's the
set covers everything from 8 bit 16 bits
32 and 64 variations of signed and
unsigned here's the interesting thing
these types are optional it's that if
you include student dot H you are not
guaranteed to get the full set you can
it's reasonable to expect to find
something like you int 32 and in 32 but
you're not guaranteed to get into 8 more
in 16 and the reason for that is that C
and C++ aspire to be languages that
compile for a wide range of target
platforms and one platform of interest
our digital signal processors which
often have word sizes which are not as
small as 8 bits or 16 bits it's not
uncommon to see a DSP with a 32-bit word
size or a 64-bit word size and that's
the smallest addressable unit on the
architecture by definition a byte in C
and C++ is the size it's an object to
size as the smallest addressable unit
it's by definition as size of 1 but it's
not guaranteed to be 8 bits
it could be 16 or 32 or 24 bits
something like that so that's why this
set is not guaranteed to be everywhere
now if you have an 8-bit processor which
is common for most desktop workstation
you're gonna get them all but if you're
concerned about writing highly portable
code this is an assumption that you
can't make so what do you do well the
[Music]
the header provides the in leased data
types and just out of curiosity how many
of you have seen these before only a
small number well here there's something
new you just learned which is that there
are these types at least eight at least
sixteen at least 32 and 64 and what this
is you use these when you say I only
need to represent in bits but I'll take
the smallest thing that will hold that
so that if you you don't need it to be
exactly 8 bits what you do is you say oh
I want at least 8 and you might get 16
or 32 bits allocated to the storage unit
but you'll get 8 that you can use now
the one thing though is you're not
guaranteed when you use these types that
the arithmetic that you use on those
will behave exactly the same as the
exact width types because when there's
overflows it'll actually propagate into
the higher order bits that you didn't
ask for so you do have to understand
that that's what you're getting you're
not getting something that's a larger
allocation with the exact same behavior
is the exact width type you're just
getting a compromise that you then have
to program carefully but it does give
you the ability to write it gives you a
slightly greater chance of writing
standard portable code to do this and
these types are required they are not
optional you're guaranteed that they
will be in the header the other set of
type deaths that
- this is inte fast n or you inte fast
ed and what does this represent this
says I would like to do arithmetic in n
bits and I would like it to be
represented in the storage unit in which
it will execute the fastest said well
why isn't why is an in fast eight
exactly eight well classic example is
the RISC processors like the classic ARM
architecture they have a decided bias
toward 32-bit arithmetic if you declare
entities which are 8 bits what the code
wants to do is take the 8 bits convert
it into a 32-bit register which requires
a movement a sign extend and does the
arithmetic in that format and then
stores it back into exactly 8 bits by
chopping it down and you can easily do
experiments with compilers on that kind
of a target and find that choosing the
exact width type actually incurs a
performance penalty for certain kinds of
arithmetic and that if you say I want
the it fast 8 version it'll just give
you a 32-bit entity so I'll store that
and you'll find that you don't pay the
penalty for the sign for the expansion
and contraction of the data type getting
it into the exact width size so this is
often or potentially a good choice for
things like a loop control variable
where you know that the index value is
still in a limited range but you say but
I want it to run fast you know it's it
would be inappropriate though to use
these things for structures in which you
have to have precise storage layout yeah
and these things exist in both C and C++
and more or less the same form other
extended integer types there's an int
Max and a you ain't Max and this is
saying I would like an integer that will
hold the largest possible value whatever
this architecture will deal with you say
no what isn't that long long int and
unsigned long long no not necessarily
because it could be on a given
architecture that long long integer is
64 bits but there is a an underscore
underscore huge int which is 128 bits on
that platform
and each since that's not standard each
compiler might give that large integer
type some other name where they might
support long long long end which is a
non-standard
datatype and this is a portable way of
saying whatever that integer type is I
want it in Max and you in max
another one is input or you nth putter
and this is I would like to have an
integer which is big enough to store all
the bits in a pointer without losing
information sometimes hopefully not very
often you need to be able to do
arithmetic other than just adding and
subtracting on a pointer you want to be
able to do operations like divides or
multiplies because you're doing some
hashing or something like that on a
pointer value and you can't do that
natively on pointers pointers all you
can do is that and subtract so you can
you say I want to convert it to an
integer what is the appropriate integer
type that I can convert it to without
losing information the answer is its
input her or you input her now this is
an optional type and that's because
there may not be an architectural
guarantee that I mean if it turns out
for example that the size of a data
point or a void star is larger than the
size of int max then there is no input
or you input her
right there's no integer big enough to
hold a pointer value without losing data
but pardon I'm not oh I can't name one
but I don't think the Standards
Committee did this simply because it was
a hypothetical I think I suspect that
such architectures do exist okay
another feature is underscored func
underscore and this is the way that you
can ask at compile time what's the name
of the function that I'm currently
compiling this is useful for doing
tracing and error messages and it's not
a macro it's actually an implicitly
defined local object right there in the
middle of the slide it shows you what
you can expect the definition for
underscore underscore func underscore
underscore to look like it's actually a
statically allocated array of characters
initialized with a string literal whose
value is the name of the function and
this is if if accessed this will be
defined for each function that use it
that refers to double underscore func
now you can only do this inside the body
of a function you can't refer to this in
other scopes and here would be a use for
it
it's for example you could define macros
that support doing runtime tracing of
each time you enter and leave a function
and what it does is it simply does
prints out a message that says I'm
entering this function with this name
and you can just put the enter and leave
macro calls inside the body of a
function like foo or bar and when you
run the program you see a trace you
probably want to make this conditional
but yes
oh I think you could use string
concatenate oh I'm sorry funk is not a
macro so I yeah pardon
yes it's actually the name of an object
so you would have to rap funk in another
macro to get string key cat and by the
time you get done with that you'd say
okay it's not worth the effort okay just
okay what's next
relax declaration ordering this one was
a no-brainer originally c90 had the
old-style where all declarations had to
be at the beginning of a block they are
syntactically they treated declarations
and statements as distinct things C++
this was introduced because it allows
you to practice the good habit of
delaying the declaration of an object
until you're ready to initialize it and
so C language said hey there's really no
reason to continue that old rigid style
let's just borrow that idea and and then
it followed that it made sense to do
this for for loops as well the old C 90
style was again to put the Declaration
of for loop control variables at the
beginning of a block and then initialize
them that way and now C 90 uses the C++
approach with the same modern scope
rules which is that the scope of a loop
control variable is it ends with the
close curly brace it ends with the body
of the controlled statement and so
that's that's just the same as C++
inlining is also a feature that c 99
borrowed from c++ the classic example is
you know doing something like that you
want to test is
and even integer but that's not a
self-evident computation I mean it's not
too hard to reverse-engineer it good
habit would be to give it a name but you
don't want to pay a price for that you'd
like to get the same code quality there
all sorts of justifications for wanting
to do inlining and the traditional way
of doing this in C was to use macros
which had a number of negative effects
one of the principal negative effects
was that macro calls don't behave
exactly like function calls in that the
argument if the arguments to the macro
call themselves have side-effects like
pre and post increments and the
expression that represented the argument
value was referenced more than once in
the body of the macro then something
like star P plus plus would be applied
more than once in that execution and you
would not get the same computed value as
if you had used the function for doing
that and so inlining has the nice
property that when you define a function
as an inline it has the same semantics
as a non inline function in a couple of
ways interestingly
inline in c99 is not underscore capital
inline it's inline the same way it is in
C++ and I'm not quite sure the rationale
for that it's interesting to me that it
wasn't done the way the others were but
I double-checked it it is a keyword and
so what happens is as you well know the
within line calls basically it takes the
body of the function and substitutes it
at the point of the call but it's not
just a textual substitution the way a
macro is it's a what happens is it will
do what it has to do in order to
guarantee that the function still has
the inline function call has functioned
like semantics so in the case of
something like calling the max value
with star P plus plus star Q plus plus
we want to make sure that the side
effect of the plus plus is don't only
done once so the a compiler would
guarantee that it would you know call
evaluate star P plus plus and capture
that value in a temporary a CPU register
and it would do that for both star P
plus plus and star Q plus plus and then
use those in the evaluation of the
comparison expression so that that's one
of the big improvements of inlining over
over macros the other one is that you
can take the address of an inline
function inline functions are functions
and you can take the address of a
function that's not net well you can do
it even if it's inline
then you've ever done that just out of
curiosity how many of you knew you could
do that this is this is behavior in C++
as well so this is nothing different and
so the question is what happens when you
take the address and the answer is it
generates a non inline copy of an inline
function now it doesn't turn all uses of
the function into a non inline function
it only happens when the call occurs
through the pointer in the other
situations the compiler is still going
to try to evaluate the the function call
as an inline yes
the question is how do what happens in
multiple compilation units I'm going to
answer that question in a slide or two
that's a good question
so let's just talk about PAC how
inlining effects packaging typically
when functions are not in lined by the
way the default I talked about this in
my lecture yesterday with having to do
with storage duration and linkage if you
if I'm telling you anything here which
doesn't quite sit right go watch the
other talk when the video comes out the
typical way that you package non inline
functions is that you put function
declarations in a header file and you
put the corresponding function
definition in a dot C or in C++ at CPP
file by default these functions have
external linkage which means that they
can be used for communication from one
separately compiled translation unit to
another if you were to place the entire
function definition in a header file and
include that header in more than one
place then you would have problems not
at compile time but at link time because
the compiler would observe oh I'm not
the compiler I misspoke the linker would
see hey that same function is defined in
more than one object file and what you
would get is a link error which says the
symbol is multiply defined well that's
expected behavior however with inline
functions you do go ahead and put the
DEF not just the Declaration but you put
the definition in the header file now if
the function is never called in a way
that forces the compiler to generate a
non inline copy all that's going to
happen is the compiler uses that
definition at the point of each call to
simply substitute the body no harm done
but the question is what happens if for
example two separate translation units
decide to take the address of that
function and the compiler says oh I got
to generate a non inline call how many
copies of the function am I going to
wind up with am I going to wind up with
a copy in each translation unit and the
answer in both C and C++ says you still
wind up with only one non inline copy
for the entire program the official
terminology we say that that that non
inline copy has external linkage and
that all no matter where the call takes
place in in any translation they wind up
going to one single copy it's not so the
compiler doesn't regard that as multiply
defined now in C++ this is all handled
automatically basically you just go
ahead and put your inline definition in
a header file and you can include that
in as many separately compiled source
files to produce object modules and at
linked time the linker is smart enough
to recognize that the non inline copies
are permitted duplicates and it throws
away all the one and it's all done
automatically but in C my understanding
is they didn't want to burden the linker
with that additional smarts so you have
if you think this is going to happen
this is where C and C++ treat in lines
differently it's that in C what you have
to do is you have to pick the spot where
you would like the non inline copy to go
if it gets used and the way you do that
is in one of the dot C files you write a
declaration but not a definition for the
inline function to say if an online copy
is to be generated here's where I want
it to be so it's interesting it's kind
of backwards from the way you do it with
non in lines which is with a non inline
you put the declaration in the header in
the
definition in a source file here you put
the definition in the header and the
declaration in the source file now and
so by the way if you want you can put
the word extern on that and it's benign
it doesn't hurt so doing it either way
in this dot C file would work you can
even say X turn in line if you prefer
that stylistically what you can't do is
just put in line by itself that will get
the compiler upset so to a large extent
in lining is the same in C and C++ with
this exception now if you go ahead and
try this for example with the new
compiler my experiences canoe is more
permissive and you may find that you can
go ahead and get it to build without
this but it is my understanding that's
non-standard they're giving you C++ like
semantics in AC environment which canoe
does that in a number of ways they'll
just it also you the default I believe
for many new distributions is that the
new C++ compiler will throw in some C
features which are not standard C++ just
because well we've got them here you can
use them and you have to actually go out
of your way to turn these things off if
they look carefully at the command
options to say no no give me just see
don't give me C augmented with some
niceties from C++ and when I was
developing the tests to verify this
stuff I had to go and find those kinds
of options because I would do stuff like
this and find canoe is compiling it and
I don't think they're right you drill
down and you find out oh they were they
were being nice to you and looking the
other way while you did something that
was non-standard okay another feature is
complex numbers the c99 added support
for comprar complex arithmetic in
rectangular
form so you can represent X plus y I
where I is the imaginary number they do
it with an extended keyword underscore
capital C complex and you can control
the precision of a complex number you
can do float double long double you can
also declare in C you can have
optionally you can have just imaginary
numbers in other words a representation
of a number with no real part only an
imaginary part now complex is required
the imaginary ones are optional not all
see implement stations have to support
that now in contrast C++ doesn't have
this as a built-in type it's done with a
template you get a lot of the same
functionality but if you want to write
code that's compatible in both languages
you have to do a little bit of dancing
around you know the type names are a
little different and C++ doesn't support
a purely imaginary type I'm not aware of
that implementation and by the way the
just like it doesn't matter whether you
say unsigned int or int unsigned it
doesn't matter what the order double
complex complex double same thing it
supports all the arithmetic that you
expect it to support and notice again
that the type name is underscore capital
C complex so if you include the header
complex dot H then you get a more
attractive spelling a lowercase C
without the underscore and the constant
complex underscore I is that's the
representation of the value of the
imaginary value 0 plus 1 I and then
there's also versions like that for
imaginary and underscore imaginary I and
then there's also if you include complex
H you also get a definition for the
symbol capital I so that's a name
conflict you might want to look out for
right not a lot of us
named variables or functions that way
but I could imagine that one might be
used somewhere okay and of course the
it's a built-in type it has a reasonable
set of conversions between the complex
types and the floating types and not
surprisingly if you convert a floating
point number into a complex number it
just assumes that the imaginary part is
0 if you take a complex value and
convert it into a floating value it
simply truncates the imaginary part so
most of this stuff does reasonably what
you expect and there are functions like
C real and see a match that allow you to
extract the real and imaginary parts and
they're also format well actually there
are no I don't think there's a format
specifier specifically for displaying
the real and imaginary parts you have to
extract the real and imaginary parts and
display them as floats ok literals let's
talk about those for a moment the the
syntactic construct called the literal
or things like well 1 or 10 or 123
that's an integer literal quote X quote
is the character literal or a double
quoted sequence is a string literal and
but if you invent a user-defined type
suppose I want to come up with with a
representation for rational numbers
where I store a numerator and a
denominator and I'd like to have the
value one half or one third you can't do
that on the fly in C 90 you actually
have to make a named constant like one
half equal to and a brace initialized
value and in c99
now you can do this kind of stuff on the
fly with a notation as shown there in
the highlighted red where you can just
put the name of the type rational in
parentheses followed by a brace enclosed
in valid initial value list and this is
what's known as a compound literal and
so that's an unnamed object temporary
object of type rational whose
structure members are initialized with a
1 into 2 and that looks similar to
something you can do in C++
now that C++ has curly brace
initializers you can do things like it
looks similar but that does that turns
out that doesn't compile a c++ c++ wants
you to get rid of the parens around the
type so you'd have to write it that way
so it's close but not quite the same in
these two languages you can also have
on-the-fly literals of an array type so
for example there I want to have an
integer array with so many elements in
it you can have the essentially write a
type name int square bracket m where m
is some constant value and then have a
bration that initializer and that will
on the fly create an array with those
elements in it and not surprisingly you
can omit from inside the square brackets
the dimension and the compiler will
figure out what the dimension is based
on the number of elements in the
initializer list again this is similar
to something you can do in C++ but C++
doesn't like those parens around the
type what you'd have to do in C++ to do
something equivalent is come up with a
named type like digits and use the name
without parentheses in front of it in
front of the curly brace to initialize
it list and do it that way so it's a
similar capability but not identical
okay that's compound lip designated
initializers one use case for this I
think one of the principal motivations
is that when you define unions and you
want to be able to initialize an element
in the Union you in C 90 you would put
for example define a glop g1 inside the
curly braces there it
would take whatever that value was and
say okay that's the initial value for
the first variant within the Union there
was no notation in c90 by which you
could say no I don't want to initialize
the int I want to initialize the double
and so in fact if you put the 12.3 there
which looks like a floating point value
and you'd say okay that means I'm going
to be initializing the double with that
value knowing what it would do is take
that twelve point three throw away the
point three turn it into an integer and
use it to initialize the int member of
the float I'm sorry yeah the int member
of the glop I misspoke and in doing that
you probably get a warning about a
truncation error but you're not mandated
to get that warning so with designated
initializers you can put a dot and the
name of the member equals and that will
now you can select which member of the
Union you want to initialize that's a
designated initializer and these are
going to be in C++ twenty they haven't
been in C++ yet but they will be coming
to a compiler near you another use for
these is suppose I have a structure type
like date and a date represents in a day
a month in a year problem is that the
North America at least the u.s.
conventions for the order of these
things are different like so much you
know the u.s. insists on doing it
differently than everybody else and so
we would in the States most people would
put the month first and then the day but
most of the rest of the world puts the
day first and then the month and the
problem is without designated
initializers you could easily get them
out of order and not know that you've
done it wrong but if you use designated
initializers you can have a slightly
higher assurance that you've got you put
together what you want you can also use
designated initializers with a raise so
for example I've got this array
with ten elements and I want it to be
zeros almost everywhere except for some
values in the middle or at the end and
you can just put square bracket three to
say I want the third eyelet the element
with index three to be initialized with
an eight the element with index seven to
be initialized with a two and everything
else will be zero if it's statically
allocated oh I think it doesn't matter I
have to check the rules on that but I
believe it's zeros even for an automatic
object okay so here are some c99
features that are not in C++ one of them
is variable-length arrays and the in C
90 and still in C++ when you declare I
should say define an array object you
have to give the dimension and that
dimension has to be expressed as a
constant expression meaning it can be an
expression with multiple operands and
operators in it as long as the whole
thing can be evaluated to get a value at
compile time it can't be a runtime
variable and this is a problem if you
have a function for example like this
function f which wants to be able to say
well I've got a parameter to the
function which represents the number of
elements that I want for an array like I
wanted I want to just have a local
variable of an array type with that many
elements and that was not native to C 90
it's not native to C++ either so you had
to do something like dynamic allocation
which then of course imposes the burden
of remembering to clean up after
yourself something that's easy to forget
to do and so it gets even worse if you
have multi-dimensional arrays because
you would have to do a more complex
computation to compute the size of the
allocation plus when you go to index the
elements you can't use multiple square
bracketed indices you have to have to do
the arithmetic
treat it as if it's a single dimension
array this was a you know a recurring
problem for people who did arithmetic on
a race array elements so with
variable-length arrays you can now do
this you can just declare a local
variable of an array type and the
dimensions can be non constant and the
compiler imposes on the runtime system
the responsibility of allocating the
storage for that and deallocating it
automatically that's what's called a
variable length array and I didn't look
carefully at very many implementations
but these are probably not on the stack
these are probably managed dynamic yes
yes mm-hmm it will crash yesterday so
yeah the implementation is not specified
as to where that storage come from it's
a matter of the runtime system deciding
whether it will use heap or I mean it's
smart you can you can often do this
stuff with stack allocation what so what
you want to do if you are going to use
these things is investigate the
allocation and de-allocation strategy
and the nice thing is with the VLA s you
can act especially with
multi-dimensional arrays you can use
multiple lis dimensioned sub scripting
and it will do the correct offset
computations for you okay and you can
also have fieles as parameters now don't
you know they're allowed to be local
objects and they're allowed to be
parameters they are not allowed to occur
outside of block scope so you can't make
these things global now the other thing
that happens is size of which for every
other data type is a compiled time
computation sizeof becomes a run time
computation for V la's
it's not it's not a constant it's not
guaranteed anymore to be a constant
expression as I say VL A's can only
appear as function parameters are in a
function body and they can't be externa
static they can't be statically
allocated interestingly this was in the
Guddu compilers early on it's hard to
find another C compiler that supports
this so much so that when C 11 came out
this became did they reclassified it as
an optional feature it was kind of like
a big oh never mind and in C++ it
doesn't exist the expectation is you're
going to use vector now flexible array
members here's a use case for this
suppose that it's not uncommon in
communication software for example that
you have packet structures where you
have a fixed size header followed by a
variable length tail and so how do you
represent that well you want to be able
to have a structure which has some fixed
layout header and then an array of a
variable dimension and the problem is
you can't use a variable e dimension
array in this context and so the common
idiom prior to c99 was to simply say
okay I'll just pick one as the dimension
of that array and then I'll just allow
the fact that she doesn't do bounds
checking and go ahead and allocate
something bigger and pretend there's a
bigger array there now the thing is that
when you do it this way you have to be
careful about how you compute the size
of the total object that you allocate
because you say okay if I want to have a
packet with n bytes in the trailing
portion what I'll do is I want to malloc
the size of the header plus n times the
size of of data actually that should
have been a data sub 0 I think
that's a type of I want the type of not
the whole right in this case the yeah so
I think it should have been size of data
sub 0 or it couldn't just oh no I
misspoke data is the tight data type so
it's n times size of data that is
correct the problem with this strategy
is drum roll yeah it's the the presence
of possible padding bytes because if the
data requires alignment the compiler is
free to put padding bytes after the
header before the first element in the
data portion and so what you have to do
actually is compute not the size of the
header but the offset of where the data
portion is and you can use the standard
offset of macro to do that so it was a
trickier computation easy to make a
mistake and so the c99 solution to this
is to use what's called a flexible array
member not to be confused with a VL a in
which you can just use empty square
brackets as the dimension of the
trailing portion of the packet and and
this is what's known as a flexible array
member and so now the computation is
that the size of the packet includes any
trailing padding bytes that might be
there ok so that that's how you work
with those
another feature restrict keyword
restrict this is another type specifier
like Const or volatile and you see this
now in the declarations of functions in
places like standard live dot H and
string dot H and actually that's a
mistake up there it's not standard live
dot H declares store copy its string dot
H but and you strict is really intended
for the Declaration of pointer
parameters that's even though it's
syntactically like Const of a little it
really doesn't have any use other than
for what you
see there now what does this mean why is
this there it's because pointer aliasing
can create problems for optimizers that
want especially on architectures that
have vector operations and in order to
be able to use optimizations which might
use vector processing instructions you
have to have confidence that the
operands to the vector operations are
non-overlapping and so essentially what
a restricted pointer means is its
permission to the compiler to say go
ahead and assume that this pointer is
the only pointer pointing to that entity
and that you're allowed to freely
reorder operations to optimize vector
operations without worrying G is the
source and the destination overlapping
in which case I would care about not
reordering things it allows the greater
caching and things like that and so
that's that's what restrict is used for
primarily so that you'll see yeah I'm
going to wrap up here that the standard
will standard definitions for these
functions now have restricts in them and
now what happens is if you go ahead and
pass in operands the two overlap the
behavior is undefined it's your
responsibility to make sure that you've
passed in data that does satisfy the
restrict constraint there are functions
like memo which don't have the restrict
there because mem move is defined to
work for possibly overlapping operands
let's just see if we have and so I'll
just mention this and wrap up at this
point which is that you know that
declarations which have array parameters
with an empty square bracket it's
essentially just a pointer and when you
declare things which are arrays of Const
or Ray's a volatile you can do them
either as pointers or square brackets
square bracket at arrays the problem is
that if you have a parameter which is a
Const
and pointer there's no comparable there
wasn't any comparable array notation you
can that do it now in c99 with putting
the Const inside the square brackets now
tell you though that's not very useful
turns out that the real use for that is
to be able to put the restrict in there
so be able to use array notation and say
that this is an array that's restricted
okay and I think that's as far as we'll
get I had a few more but I think I'll
just leave it at that because somebody
else has to speak in this time slot so I
hope you found this useful Thanks
[Applause]